here Washington we have counsel to the
president for a preview Kellyanne Conway
is with us Kellyanne I think John
Roberts summed it up right the complete
verifiable irreversible denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula on top of what
has already happened which we can
officially say is historic and that is
there just by the way we're watching Kim
jong-un and the president let's watch
this as they meet shaking hands history
in the making
that was a photo-op now we are expecting
we are expecting in about what's
listening
[Music]
[Music]
to accomplish there
Media is now shouting questions what you
like to accomplish first it's scheduled
to be a 45-minute meeting many expect
that it might go on a little bit longer
a lot of talks have gone on all
throughout the day yesterday throughout
the night tonight and leading into this
morning it's 9 a.m. here in Singapore
and we do expect that about well maybe
15 minutes from right now that the
president and Kim jong-un or at least
the president will be making a statement
when that happens we'll bring it to you
live but let me go back to Kelly and
Conway counsel to the president for just
a minute the complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula but we already have a
lot that's happened here we've
dismantled one nuclear test site at
least Kim jong-un has we have three
American hostages have been released
missiles stop being fired back in
December over Japan the sabre-rattling
has stopped they're actually talking
about new denuclearization and some
hardliners have been well let's just say
expunged or removed from power so a lots
happened leading up to this that really
paved the way for this Kelley yeah
that's right Shawn and peace and
progress have already won these steps
that have been made a truly are historic
everybody who's watching is witnessing
history congratulations to you for
securing the first post summit interview
with President Trump and I know that
he'll he will tell you what he thought
of today but remember what he has said
already which is that this president
knows that sometimes negotiations like
this take 1 2 3 4 5 or more meetings you
can't change 70 years of war and a
country that has isolated itself from
most of the rest of the world as it
becomes nuclear capable and you can't
expect that to turn around in the day or
a meeting but let's remember what
changed what changed from past
presidents attempts it's the leadership
and the vision of President Trump it's
his ability to reframe the way we look
at relations around the globe and I'll
tell you this is not an American issue
the denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula is everybody's business this
benefits the world and that's also why
President Trump has brought onboard the
south
Korean president mr. Abbey from Japan he
keeps including folks from the region in
the conversations he's been preparing
for this for quite a while insofar as he
has been conferring with and receiving
briefings from folks who are versed in
the region and certainly votes versed
with respect to nukes and and here we
are you're right we're way ahead of the
game but there's something about
President Trump accepting the invitation
from North Korea to at least sit down
and start the talks and Shawn you know
there were people this weekend who were
saying they hope the summit fails they
hope the economy tanks folks don't bet
against peace in progress for the world